hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to continue the explanation of
Science Fiction live action movie called
assassination classroom graduation the
story will still revolve around a
classroom that was assigned a mission to
assassinate their own teacher who turns
out to be a yellow squid like weird
creature this movie has a very unique
concept about the relationship between
students and teacher and also has a very
deep moral story behind it make sure to
watch it till the end to find out for
those who haven't watched the first part
feel free to click the link below in the
description
half of the year has passed but the
students from class 3E have not been
able to assassinate chorusensei their
weird squid-like teacher who plans to
destroy the Earth on graduation day at
the beginning of the movie Coro Sensei
is interviewing his students regarding
what they want to do after graduation
but as usual his students still try to
seek the opportunity to assassinate
their teacher among the students Nagisa
the main protagonist in the movie is
still unable to find out what he wants
after he graduates
a representative from the ministry of
Defense tells the class that there will
be a school Festival next week which
will be attended by students from other
schools and people from the city he also
adds that this will be the perfect
opportunity for class 3E students to
plan the assassination because Coro
sensei's attention will surely be
distracted making him the easy target of
killing given the opportunity karasima
states that the ministry of defense will
also send a sniper named red eye thus
the students should assassinate
chorusensei before the sniper does
long story short the Festival begins in
corosensei disguises himself as a clown
so that he won't be recognized by the
people but even though korosensei
exposes himself in open space the sniper
still struggles to lock his aim to the
weird creature the theater show for
class 3 he has started however the
students and the sniper are having a
hard time catching and assassinating
korosensei surprisingly the teacher also
manages to spot the sniper and
humiliates him as he brings the sniper
down to participate in the show
corusensei even complements the sniper
after the show for motivating their
students to prepare their best for
assassination
after the school Festival ends one of
the class 3E students kaide Kayano
catches corusensei off guard and manages
to surround corusensei by using
anti-teacher fibers to limit his
movement she then begins her assault by
revealing her tentacles and starts
attacking the yellow creature endlessly
surprisingly she reveals that she is
actually the younger sister of aguri
yukimura who was the class's former
teacher and accuses korosensei a
murderer she wants to take revenge
against corusensei for having supposedly
killed her sister this event leaves all
students of class 3E confused urging the
teacher to tell the truth to them but
porosensei refuses to answer and tells
them that he will tell his past after
Kayano comes back as she is still part
of class 3E
Kiana reflects on the past year when she
went to aguri's workplace to deliver a
package there suddenly a big explosion
occurs Kayano easily made her way
through the rubble to find a tentacled
creature standing beside her sister
before fleeing coyote sees her sister's
dead body and a note saying that the
perpetrator will be teaching at Kuna
gigioka Junior High in preparation for
her revenge she also took the vials
without thinking and injected them into
herself making her a tentacled creature
back to the present Kayano confronts
Coro Sensei while he is cosplaying
himself as a dog and challenges
corusensei to a duel she manages to get
corusensei cornered with her fire
tentacles but it will drain her energy
much faster knowing that the
experimental tentacles she wears is
taxing her life force Cora Sensei allows
himself to get attacked and tells the
students to calm her down Nagisa manages
to distract her with a kiss and Coro
Sensei manages to cut off the Tentacles
from Kiana
korosensei realizes that the battle has
been observed by the white cloaked man
who was previously seen to be a toner's
guardian corusensei confronts him and
manages to see his true identity who
turns out to be Yanagi Sawa we'll get
into him later
after the battle korosensei decides to
tell the class about his past he reveals
that he was actually a human who worked
as an assassin called sinigami or god of
death two years ago due to his strength
and intelligence an unofficial research
organization led by yanagisawa captured
him making him a test subject for
antimatter experiments surprisingly the
Assassin was monitored by aguri who
turns out to be yanagusawa's fiancee
time flies and both of them managed to
develop a close relationship especially
after she revealed that she was a
teacher during the daytime aguri
revealed that she loved her job as a
teacher so much and was very motivated
to help the students in class 3E to
become a better person one day exactly
one year after the first time the
Assassin and Guri had met yanagisawa
found out that the mouse tested on the
moon had destroyed 70 of the Moon
realizing that the same thing would
occur on the Assassin's body and could
destroy the Earth thus he ordered the
disposal of the Assassin before it was
too late knowing this the Assassin plans
to retaliate with his hidden power from
the test and live until he eventually
self-destructs and destroys the world
yanogisawa launched a weapon called
tentacle mines to kill him but the
Assassin was protected by a Guri causing
her to be stabbed by the weapon and died
on the spot this event made the Assassin
change his mind leading him to make a
vow with a Guri to teach class 3E
back to the present chorusensei states
that he will still die in March next
year thus he wants to be killed by his
own students because of the bond they
have developed for the past six months
after hearing the shocking story all
students of class 3 become speechless
even during the winter break no students
could plot an assassination long story
short Nagisa decides to find a way to
save korosensei instead of killing him
but several students including Karma
disagree with his opinion causing the
class to split into two big groups
korosensei suddenly comes and suggests
in gisa and Karma to do a one-on-one
battle to decide which side will win the
fight is quite dramatic and is watched
by the other students eventually after a
long fight Karma manages to beat Nagisa
and is going to stab magisa with a knife
but karma suddenly surrenders after
realizing that Nagisa really wants to
help the teacher and Karma is ready to
help him
ritsu manages to collect all the
classified information related to
corusensei finding that it is possible
to make a drug to save their teacher to
gather more information the students
plan to sneak into yanagusawa's lab and
manage to steal a file from there after
that the class begins to work on an
antidote based on the data stolen from
yanagusawa's Lab a few moments later the
class manages to complete the antidote
and it is ready to be given to
chorusensei on the other side the
government decides to use a laser beam
ignited by a satellite as a last resort
to kill chorusensei while corusensei is
alone karasima orders to launch an
anti-super being barrier which isolates
the yellow creature in the classroom the
government agents also kidnap the
students of class 3E and lock them in a
tunnel karasima explains that the kidnap
has to be done so that they won't try to
do some silly and dangerous stuff in
order to help corresensei however the
students managed to find a way in Escape
while escaping they meet karasima
instead of returning them back into the
prison he encourages the students to
help corusensei surprisingly the
students are also helped by Arena she
manages to distract the military by
shooting randomly with her grenade
launcher long story short after an epic
battle against the Military Officers the
students of class 3 reached the
classroom and meet korosensei there
korosensei is impressed by the effort
made by the students to help him they
hand over the antidote and force Coro
Sensei to drink it but suddenly
yanagusawa confronts them he explains
that they have been tricked by him
because the file that was previously
stolen from his lab was faked yanokisawa
states that he wants revenge for what
corusensei had done before and starts to
inject several artificial tentacle
liquid transforming himself into a
horrifying monstrous being he is way
more stronger than korosensei and
manages to tear corosensei apart seeing
him easily defeating korosensei Kyoto
attempts to protect him only causing her
to get stabbed in the process filled
with anger because having to see the
tragedy from two years ago repeats for a
Sensei casts a very strong laser beam
which eliminates yanagisawa instantly
learning from his previous mistake for a
Sensei learns how to do a surgery and
manages to save kyano's life with his
skill after the fight Cora Sensei
becomes very weak and tells the students
that this is the time to kill him he
urges the students to kill him or he
will be killed by the laser beam nagiso
offers himself to be one to perform the
assassination while the other students
holds corusensei's tentacles after a
very dramatic moment where korosensei
says his last words Nagisa finally stabs
the knife into corusensei's heart
causing chorusensei to disappear and his
body dissipates into many particles of
yellowish light the ending shows that
korosensei always wants to be killed
before he explodes and causes any threat
to the planet in the end the man who was
seemingly the villain of the story was
actually the hero he not only makes the
best out of his last few days on Earth
but also manages to inspire his students
to be a better person
several years later Nagisa has finally
found his goal and decides to become a
teacher for delinquents
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching